[Musique]
au Japon l'hiver ne désarme pas et la
ville de nagoyaka dans le nord du pays
pourrait tant d'autres circonstances
sans orgueillir d'un bulletin
d'enneigement que lui envierait bien des
stations de sports d'hiver
[Musique]
émergent des ouvertures du second étage
la population de la ville s'est
courageusement attaquée au déblème
entreprise dérisoire car sur des
dizaines de kilomètres la nature est un
fruit sous 4 mètres de neige
la circulation des trains a été
totalement interrompue
des milliers de voyageurs dont beaucoup
furent bloqués pendant des jours dans
leurs wagons cherchèrent un réconfort
dans la prière
[Musique]
les parachutages de vivre ont été
effectués pour parer aux besoins les
plus urgents le premier bilan est lourd
un millier de maisons détruites
[Musique]
plus de 10000 travailleurs ont été
mobilisés pour rétablir les liaisons
indispensables mais que faire de toute
cette neige par train entier elle a dû
être transportée vers les cieux plus
clément du Sud
[Musique]
est un Guy première étape de leur séjour
en Nouvelle-Zélande la reine Elizabeth
est le duc des Dingo se sont fait
présenter la haute société locale avant
d'entendre 10000 Maoris en costume
traditionnel exprimé bruyamment leur
allégresse
la Nouvelle-Zélande célébrait ce jour-là
c'est 123 ans de fidélité la souveraine
le 11e anniversaire de son règne
[Musique]
à défaut des skyblults que l'Amérique
lui refuse l'Angleterre s'équipe en
missiles opérationnel blue style 24
d'entre eux ont été présentés à la base
de scamton de construction entièrement
britannique les Blue Style utilisent du
carburant liquide
[Musique]
le Scadron 6 17 celui des forceurs de
barrage de la dernière guerre sera le
premier équipé de blues style à Eugies
nucléaire Jacques missile possède une
puissance de destruction 50 fois
supérieure à celle de la bombe atomique
d'Hiroshima les 24 blues style
disponibles représentent la force de
frappe de trois sous-marins pourvu de
fusées Polaris les bombardiers Vulcains
peuvent lâcher leur missiles à 300 km de
l'objectif
ils sont près de 2 millions vivants dans
les montagnes arithes du nord de l'Irak
[Musique]
les luttes de leur village disent assez
la pauvreté de ces hommes rudes que sont
les Kurdes cette minorité cependant est
assez jalouse de ces particularismes
pour avoir pris le parti de les défendre
les armes à la main
et le spectacle les quotidiens d'un
partisan apprenante aux enfants d'un
village le maniement d'un fusil
[Musique]
un an et demi les Kurdes étaient entrés
en révolte contre Kacem une révolte qui
ne disposait que de faibles moyens mais
qu'animait des hommes à la détermination
farouche
leur chef nous la Mustapha Barzani avait
précisé son but à un reporter européen
l'autonomie au sein de l'État irakien
certes mais d'abord la chute de celui
qu'il désignait comme un tyran le
général cassette
du reste n'avait pas chez les Kurdes que
des ennemis irréductibles une minorité
lui restait apparemment fidèle mais il
est beau annonçaient plusieurs fois
l'écrasement définitif de la rébellion
cette brigades de l'armée irakiennement
d'entamer la résistance kurde qui aura
finalement contribué indirectement à la
chute du Zaïre
talattaque et faisant des prisonniers
parmi les soldats réguliers coupant les
ponts pour se retrancher dans la
montagne cette armée fantôme ne pue
jamais être réduites
[Musique]
elle le fut d'autant moins qu'il arrive
à même d'un tel localité ou d'un tel
autre que la combativité des deux camps
se Moussa au point qu'une tacite
coopération s'établit entre les forces
du gouvernement et les partisans Kurdes
ce n'était pas l'aspect le moins curieux
de cette guerre devenu semble-t-il un
règlement de compte personnel entre les
Kurdes et le général Kacem
[Musique]
ce dernier multipliant les oppositions
avec fini par être pratiquement isolé à
Bagdad après l'avoir chassé du ministère
de la défense où il s'était réfugié les
officiers conjurés l'ont abattu
[Musique]
au lendemain du coup d'État l'épuration
sévissait à Bagdad les chars achetés aux
Russes par Kacem donnait la chasse aux
communistes les soldats posaient pour
les photographes
[Musique]
prêt Cassel
élimine les problèmes sont-ils résolus
pour autant la révolte kurde ayant aussi
pour objet d'obtenir l'autonomie les
montagnards ne sont pas disposées pour
l'instant à déposer purement et
simplement les arbres
les Kurdes ont vu durant un an et demi
brûler leur village et ils n'ont pas
cédé puissantes minorités de l'Irak il
continue de représenter le problème
numéro 1 pour les nouveaux maîtres de
Bagdad
[Musique]
l'étude des volcans ne requiert pas que
des qualités d'hommes de science c'est
ce que prouve le film qui a rapporté
haruntaiev de sa dernière expédition
hivernale sur le plus grand volcan
d'Europe l'Etna les membres de la
mission du Centre national de
vulcanologie avec leurs deux chevaux
Sahara ont dû utiliser des bandes de
treillis métalliques pour vaincre au
milieu d'une tourmente polaire la neige
molle entassée dans les creux si bien
que c'est un véritable exploit qu'on
réalisait à la fois le véhicule et les
hommes à l'occasion d'une simple mission
de routine une de ses missions
régulières qui ont pour but en quelque
sorte la surveillance du turbulent
volcan sicilien
depuis 1960 des spécialistes belges
français et italiens se donnent ainsi
périodiquement rendez-vous à 3325 mètres
au bord de ce cratère dont les colères
ont tant de fois éprouvé les hommes là
il se livre à une auscultation 1 règles
les enregistrements sismologiques leur
permettent de prendre si l'on peut dire
le poux du volcan qui depuis 12 ans n'a
pratiquement passé c'est d'accuser une
certaine fière
Haroun tajev et ses compagnons
complètent leurs observations par des
prélèvements de lave et de gaz au point
précis où le rock en fusion apparaît à
l'air libre
[Musique]
part de telles visites les éruptions
catastrophiques du célèbre volcan
sicilien peuvent être sinon prévenu du
moins prévu par ces modernes médecins du
globe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]